I'm detective Chief superintendent
Airman Corrigan leading the
investigation into the attempted murder
of detective Chief Inspector John
Caldwell
it is now two weeks to the day since
this horrific attack took place in front
of terrified children and adults at a
sports center in almost Kelly Clark Road
DCI Caldwell remains in a critical but
stable condition in hospital after he
was shot up to 10 times by Two Gun men
as he packed up after coaching a youth
football team
we are working tirelessly
to bring those responsible to Justice
today I'm in a position to say that I
believe a second Ford Fiesta Vehicle was
used in the attempted murder of DCI
Caldwell
it is also a blue Ford Fiesta of a
similar model
the second car had the registration
number rlz
9805 and was bought in the Glen Gormley
area of Belfast towards the end of
January
I believe this car traveled to Belfast
around this time
it was then driven from Belfast at
approximately 1pm on Wednesday the 22nd
of February
the day of the attack on John
and traveled along the M1 in the
direction of coal Island and Oma
it was found burnt out in the orbo
industrial estate the following day
Thursday the 23rd of February
I would like to know where it was stored
and its movements during this period of
time
today I'm also releasing new CCTV
footage of the first blue Ford Fiesta as
it traveled into coal Island at around
10 pm on the night of the 21st
it had the registration number
mgz
6242 but was traveling on false plates
the false plates were F or Zed
8414 and this was prior to the attack
previous CCTV footage issued shows this
blue Ford Fiesta leaving the sports
complex and turning left onto Kelly
Clark Road immediately after the
shooting
we then not travel past Glendale service
station to the rockopla road where it
was abandoned and sat on fire
we have established that this first blue
Ford Fiesta was purchased in ballyclare
on Wednesday the 8th of February
and was observed traveling towards
Belfast on the M2 Motorway that night
it was also noted leaving Belfast at
around 9 30 pm on Tuesday the 21st of
February again the night before the
attack on John
it traveled along the Almond Bay
intercool Island at around 10 pm
my appeal today is for anyone who knows
where either of these two cars were kept
prior to the shooting or has knowledge
of their movements on the day of the
shooting to come forward
we need this information
I'm also appealing for anyone who
observed anything suspicious in the
recopla road area of oma on the night of
the shooting
and an art bow the following night
Thursday the 23rd of February
did you see anyone or any vehicles in
these areas
Did You observe any Vehicles driving
away at speed
we really need you to come forward with
this information to help the
investigation and bring those
responsible for this attack on John to
Justice
I'm going to hand over now to Mick Duffy
Crime Stoppers director of operations
who will provide an update on the reward
being offered for information leading to
the arrest and conviction of the people
involved in attempting to murder John
good morning
firstly I on behalf of everybody at
Crime Stoppers wish to express our great
sadness and shock at this awful attack
on DCI Caldwell and our thoughts are
with him and his family at this time
I'm the director of operations at the
independent charity Crime Stoppers and
like John I'm also the father of a young
family and a kids football coach
so this despicable attack really
resonates with me as I'm sure it does
with many others here in Northern
Ireland and Beyond
I want to start by explaining what our
charity is what we do to keep people
safe and then announce on a significant
increase to the reward we're offering
firstly and importantly I want people to
know that we are not the police
we obviously work closely with them
and we pass on a significant amount of
anonymous information from the public
every day
but I want to assure you we are totally
independent from them
the police know that we cannot pass on
personal information about those who
contact us because we simply do not have
that ourselves
this means that when somebody contacts
the charity there are no courts no
police
no witness statements and no comeback
tell us what you know and then you're
done
I now want to turn to our reward
we know the original twenty thousand
pounds for information leading to John's
attackers has encouraged people to come
forward
and this is positive and we are told
it's making a difference
like everyone across Northern Ireland
Beyond we want those responsible for the
shooting to be brought to Justice
today with this I want to announce sorry
today
I want to announce that with through the
generosity of anonymous donors in
Northern Ireland we are now increasing
our reward for information leading to
the arrest and conviction up to a total
of a hundred and fifty thousand pounds
this is one of the highest rewards the
charity has ever offered and this money
is available to you
if it leads to the conviction of the
shooting
if you have information but prefer not
to speak to the police contact us by
visiting our website
search online at Crimestoppers UK
or by calling our 24 7 contact center on
the free phone number 0800 treble five
treble one
you can only claim the reward if you
come to Crime Stoppers
like our phone and online reporting
service our rewards process is also
Anonymous you just need to ask for a
reward code
if you know who was involved and have
information come to us and keep safe
thank you for your time today
we're keeping an open mind as to the
exact role of the second car
but we do believe that due to the
information we have around the purchase
the movements and the fact that both
cars were burned out shortly after the
attack on Jon that they were both
involved in the attack in some way
heard from the ACC Market
there's a new area
and put the suspects collaborated with
including people perhaps loyalist what
can you send us about where you are and
respective
this attack was carried out by the new
Ira that is the main line of inquiry I'm
aware of speculation around the
background of those involved
the background of the people involved is
either terrorists
nature organized crime nature or both
but this attack was carried out by the
new IRA and that is our main line of
inquiry
these people are quite clearly very
dangerous and we need information to put
them behind bars where they should be so
I'm pleased today that working with
Crime Stoppers we are in a position
to offer a reward of 150 000 pounds that
is a significant award it's a
significant amount of money so please
anyone Supply what information you know
to Crime Stoppers and leave their ass to
us
fresh CCD
course
yes
yes the blue Ford Fiesta the first
vehicle burned the registration Mark frz
8414 traveled into coal Island at around
10 pm on the evening of the 21st
our main aim is to bring people in front
of the courts but we deal with the
evidence we have and we follow the
evidence so while some disappointed that
we haven't brought people before the
courts at this stage
these investigations are particularly
challenging and they take time
the investigation is at a very early
stage
and we will use any information that is
supplied to us the reward is significant
and we need people to come forward that
one little piece of information May
close a gap that we have
we'll do the same because the
commissioner has been contacted
us are there any significant growth
we're working closely with our
colleagues in the AGS and that's all I'm
prepared to say around that at this
moment in time
can we possibly just ask you about the
biggest threat to psi officers
the amp threat and the timing offered is
completely vile sickening and disgusting
we're taking the amp threat seriously
and all staff are regularly reminded and
have been reminded about their own
personal security on and off Judy
okay thank you everybody
foreign